everyone keeps talking about how encanto
doesn't have a villain well everyone is
wrong dolores is the villain of encanto
and i'm about to prove it
hello internet welcome to film theory
where i'm doing this video to justify
the hundreds of hours of my life i've
spent watching in kanto that's not even
an exaggeration in kanto is my
three-year-old ali's first ever movie
obsession excellent choice on his part
couldn't be prouder but if you know how
three-year-olds work you know that it
means i've watched this thing so many
times that i'm approaching the heat
death of the universe everyone is his
favorite character every song is his
favorite song and at this point i've had
to explain the cracks and casita so many
times that the kid is well on his way to
becoming a structural engineer i don't
quite have the heart to tell him that
hugs won't repair drywall we'll have to
save that lesson until he turns four
obviously i'm joking casita isn't made
of drywall but rather a combination of
stone bamboo and clay in the traditional
latin american construction style called
baja wreck you can actually see the
bamboo structure here while mirabelle
chases bruno through the walls that said
when casita collapses you don't actually
see any of the bamboo or really any of
the interior structural components of
the house instead it's just a lot of
stone and plaster where did the inside
of this house go disney could it be
casita's magic could it be secret hidden
lore could it be that i've watched this
movie one too many times yes definitely
the last one as you might have figured
out around watch 37 i started to notice
some crazy details inside this thing to
help keep me sane like here where tia
peppa covers the ears of a stuffed teddy
bear while she's talking about he who
shall not be named or here where it
looks like they gave mirabelle's father
some hidden mickey ears or how the
closing song literally brings together
every other song from the show while
also giving me some strong spring
awakening vibes
[Music]
of course i'd be remiss if i didn't
mention the fact that luisa's coliseum
is filled with donkeys cheering her on
and of course i have to get this rant
off my chest but when mirabelle climbs
to the top of bruno's room what she's
climbing on doesn't actually exist in
the overhead shot you can actually tell
based on her angle relative to the door
that she's supposedly facing and don't
even get me started on how there's
nothing for her to anchor her swing from
and that her swing's momentum doesn't
match the angle of her landing you can
tell that this was probably at one point
a montage that was cut down to one final
swing in the final release just saying
the bruno's room scene really bothered
me but of everything in this movie no
character has quite as many interesting
animation details as dolores like here
and we don't talk about bruno where the
fish girl the only non-family member in
the lineup gets replaced in the dancing
with dolores so weird detail right
probably some leftover element from the
production but what's really interesting
are dolores character details like here
where she's forced to cover her ears
when the fireworks start going off
because of her super hearing or here
where she claps using only two fingers
because again doing more than that would
hurt her ears or here where she casts an
evil side eye to her cousin isabella
hold on what that sort of a
passive-aggressive look isn't something
that i would expect to see out of a
sweet unassuming character like dolores
i mean this is a character that a ton of
people stand for being the unsung hero
of the family but then i did what i tend
to do i dug a bit deeper and i really
started to think about what we see and
hear from dolores throughout this movie
and bit by bit the pieces started to add
up dolores is actively working against
the family she is miserable she is sick
of getting passed over and she's
weaponizing mirabelle in order to
sabotage the family and extinguish the
miracle oh i'm sorry is that an
uncomfortable truth i just have one
thing to say to that let's start off
with some of the details i already
mentioned about dolores gift we're told
in the opening song that because of her
super gift of hearing she
and it doesn't seem to be much of an
exaggeration as we see that she's able
to hear conversations happening
elsewhere in town likely behind closed
doors do we have a date tonight
he wants five babies and while that
seems like it'd be a cool power in
theory in actual practice this thing
would be miserable her sound sensitivity
doesn't seem like it's able to turn off
as it makes her actively recoil when
things like fireworks go off around her
as a result we see that she's constantly
hearing information that she doesn't
want to be picking up no one has to know
i know
it's also something that scientifically
would slowly be driving her insane you
see the amygdala is this little group of
neurons roughly in the center of the
brain that helps us with emotional
responses specifically when processing
fear responses when she cowers because
of those fireworks boom big ol shot of
amygdala activity as her fight-or-flight
response kicks in because those sorts of
jarring sounds are important for a human
survival they tend to jump the line so
to speak when it comes to processing
it's actually believed that that's one
of the reasons why the amygdala is in
the center of the brain it gives a close
proximity to all the other important
functions of the brain again to jump
start our survival instinct the thing is
because dolores hearing is so good she
would actually be inundated with these
sorts of inputs all the time
experiencing a constant sensory overload
we're talking about someone who can
literally hear an eye twitching from a
completely different room of the house
the only one worried about the magic is
you
and the rats talking in the walls
oh elisa i heard her eye twitching all
night her life spent hearing everything
in the town and walls around her would
be miserable she'd barely be able to
focus on anything or get a night's rest
but it's a blessing it can't be that bad
these powers are meant to be a miracle i
hear you're saying and sure some of the
powers are admittedly really cool but
dolores tia peppa and bruno well they
got the short end of the stick on that
one healing with food great super
strength awesome controlling the weather
fine in theory but having your own
private rain cloud follow you around
while you're in a bad mood thereby
making your bad mood even worse yeah
that's gonna suck
clearly the face of someone feeling
hashtag blessed and it's worth
remembering tia peppa is dolores mom
that powers just seemed to run on that
side of the family i guess bruno
meanwhile got himself a gift that
literally gets the entire town to hate
him and has affected him mentally to
such a degree that he feels like he must
constantly perform superstitious luck
rituals that is not a blessing also can
we just talk about bruno's room the
giant cliff side of stone a room that
was again bestowed upon him by the
miracle yeah that sucks too even the
movie acknowledges this one i left my
tower which was you know a lot of stairs
and dolores well as we discussed while
everyone else is clapping and watching
fireworks she's waving her fingers
around and covering her ears when
everyone else is peacefully eating
dinner she's forced to listen to her
unrequited love talk about his proposal
plans her life sucks while mirabelle
feels sad about not being special in her
super-powered family dolores has it so
much worse because she has powers that
actively work against her living a happy
life if saving herself and her mother
tia peppa from these miserable cursed
powers isn't a motive to try and end the
family's magic i don't know what is oh
wait i do know another motive for
dolores in addition to you know getting
herself out of the immense sensory
overload that she's constantly being
subjected to destroying the magic also
might help with the whole unrequited
love thing in we don't talk about bruno
we learned that bruno's prediction for
dolores was that
mariano
[Music]
aka isabella it's likely that dolores
could want to destroy the family's magic
in an effort to either a derail bruno's
prediction or b sabotage the engagement
with isabella thereby allowing mariano
to be free for her i mean we see how
eager she is to scoop him up when he
becomes a free agent at the end of the
movie have you met dolores
okay i'll take it from here goodbye but
working against the family to do it
seems like a bit much right wrong let's
actually go back to the moment that i
mentioned in the intro her evil side eye
to isabella watch the scene when asked
whether there's a date for mariano's
proposal we get this
do we have a date
tonight
he wants five babies
and pause in this one look we actually
get a huge revelation about dolores
motivations in this movie she's not just
sad about mariano marrying someone else
she actively resents isabella's
relationship with him in fact the way i
see it she might have even made up the
whole he wants five kids line in order
to freak isabella out maybe even scare
her away it does seem to have quite the
impact and if you think well that's too
sinister of a move for her really it's
not from the opening moments of the
movie dolores is established to be very
self-serving when the children of the
town are harassing mirabelle about her
gift something that mirabelle is clearly
uncomfortable admitting based on her
whole song and dance trying to deflect
away from their questions dolores just
pops out and exposes her with nothing
but a shrug later when mirabelle's
trying to hype dolores up with mariano
she literally just shoves her out of the
way and that's just the petty stuff what
about all the times that she actively
goes out of her way to explicitly
sabotage members of her family look at
the information that she does and
doesn't choose to withhold in the movie
at the proposal dinner it's dolores who
decides to start the chain of events
that makes the night into a mess despite
knowing the chaos that it would cause
she actively passes on the information
about mirabelle finding the vision the
first opportunity that she gets and
instead of staying quiet at the climax
of the meal she blurts it out
why why would she do this because she's
a gossip that has no self-control no
that's not a good enough reason in fact
the movie tells us exactly what's going
on a couple minutes prior go back to the
lyrics of we don't talk about bruno in
the final round while everyone's singing
a reprise of their earlier verses it's
tricky to make out dolores lyric but her
words actively change from the first
time she sang it the first time it goes
he told me the man of my dreams would be
just out of reach betrothed to another
it's like i hear him now but when she
sings it again it changes he told me the
man of my dreams would be just out of
reach betrothed to another another and
i'm fine and i'm fine and i'm fine and
i'm fine she repeats it four times
something tells me that she's not
actually fine going into that dinner and
while she's more than eager to share
that bit of information with the family
to ruin the proposal dinner look at what
information she chooses to withhold from
everyone she doesn't stick up for
mirabelle the first time the cracks
appear again this is someone who can
literally hear an eye twitching and yet
she doesn't hear any of the cracks that
have been forming in the house since
bruno left and since mirabelle's failed
gifting ceremony that is frankly not
possible wait
have you been in here
patching the cracks it means that she's
willfully hiding that information and
speaking of willfully hiding information
bruno in the walls while the rest of the
family thinks that he disappeared or ran
away dolores knows that he's been hiding
in the walls for years
to hurt him every day and yet again she
never reveals that information to anyone
a human being her own family member is
living in the walls of her house and she
does nothing about it my guess is that
it's because he's the one who predicted
that she'd suffer and be overlooked but
regardless the reason you gotta admit
that is cold but do you want the biggest
proof that this is intentional not just
me overthinking some random moments in
the movie look at the final door when
casita collapses everyone loses their
powers and all of a sudden dolores life
is on the up and up she and her mother
no longer have to deal with their awful
curse powers she's finally able to be
seen by the man of her dreams
i see you and i hear you but then after
they rebuild casita the madrigals get a
new door that depicts the entire family
excited that the magic has returned
everyone is happy in this door picture
with an upturned mouth everyone except
for dolores eyes downcast and literally
the only person without an upturned
mouth it is weird it is a really strange
detail in a series of strange details
all around this character here's the tl
dr friends dolores is old enough to know
about bruno's prediction in fact she
knows that mirabelle is somehow
connected to all the cracks in the walls
and that the family is scared of
mirabelle killing the miracle and
knowing that notice who knocks over the
first domino dolores she's the one that
points mirabelle in the direction of
louisa she's the one that continues to
sew family discord by dropping truth
bombs during important dinners she's the
one actively concealing the cracks while
also covering up family members living
in the walls she's the one made
miserable by her power and the one
forced to live in jealousy of her cousin
and she's the one the only one to look
sad on the final door when everyone's
powers return in storytelling a villain
is a character whose actions oppose the
positive resolution of the plot
everything dolores does and doesn't do
throughout the movie actively drives
more cracks into the house and goes to
extinguish the miracle if that my
friends isn't a villain i don't know
what is and that theorists is how the
casita crumbles but hey that's just a
theory a film theory
[Music]
you